MEETING TO ORDER --
MADAM SECRETARY DO ESTABLISH QUORUM
AND WOULD YOU PLEASE KALRA.
MEMBERS MATH RICHARD HERE
RATCHET YOU HEAR ACOSTA HERE
COSTA HERE CHAU.
CHAO HERE EGGMAN [inaudible]
FLORA.
FLORA HERE LIMON MCCARTY.
MCCARTY HERE MELENDEZ REYES.
REST HERE STONE.
WE HAVE A QUORUM.
ALRIGHT HERE WE ARE HERE TO HEAR
ONE BILL AND THAT IS ASSEMBLY
BILL --
NINETY SEVEN BEING PRESENTED BY
SIMPLY MEMBER COME LIKE A DOVE --
THERE IS COLLIGAN DOUBT WHICH IT
PLEASE.
I'M FOR IT.
ALONG WITH THE ERROR SUPPORTING
WITNESSES.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
SIGN HERE TO PRESENT ON AB.
NINE EIGHT SEVEN AB NINE EIGHT
SEVEN IS FIRST AND FOREMOST
ABOUT JOBS AND ECONOMIC EQUITY.
FOR COMMUNITIES IN AND AROUND MY
DISTRICT.
BUT WE ALSO WORKED VERY HARD TO
DEMONSTRATE THAT IN CALIFORNIA.
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION ARE NOT
MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE.
IN FACT COMPARED TO PAST
PROJECTS OF SIMILAR TYPE AND
SCOPE WE ACTUALLY BELIEVE THIS
PROJECT IS NOTHING LESS THAN THE
GOLD STANDARD FOR GREEN PROJECTS.
THAT IS IN PART DUE TO THE CHAIR
AND HIS STAFF'S [inaudible]
DILIGENT HONEST AND VERY HARD
WORK TO HELP MAKE THIS BILL
STRONGER.
CLEANER AND GREENER SO THANK YOU.
AS A RESULT THIS BILL
SIMULTANEOUSLY OFFERS THE
PROMISE OF THOUSANDS OF NEW
LOCAL JOBS FOR MY COMMUNITIES
AND THE PROMISE OF CUTTING EDGE
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS AND
POLLUTION REDUCTIONS. EIGHTY
NINE EIGHT SEVEN GUARANTEES THAT
THE NEW PRIVATELY FUNDED.
AND FINANCE CLIPPERS ARENA IN
INGLEWOOD MEETS THE HIGHEST
ENVIRONMENTAL STANDARDS
INCLUDING A FULL AND
COMPREHENSIVE III OUR LEAD GOLD
CERTIFICATION.
ANNETTE ZERO ENERGY STANDARD
WHICH IS THE HIGHEST IN THE
NATION 15% REDUCTION IN VEHICLE
TRIPS I TRANSPORTATION
MANAGEMENT PLAN AND TRANSIT
DESIGN INSISTENCE.
ON SITE AND LOCAL MITIGATION A
THIRTY MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
INTO EMISSION REDUCTION SOLAR
ROOFING AND MEASURABLE METRICS
TOWARDS EMISSION GOALS.
WITH PENALTIES ATTACHED.
FUNDAMENTALLY WE BELIEVE THAT
SIMILAR PRIVATELY FUNDED
PROJECTS IN COMMUNITIES SUCH AS
SAN FRANCISCO IN RIGHT HERE IN
SACRAMENTO ARE PROVIDING CLEAR
AND MEASURABLE THEN IT BENEFITS
FOR BOTH THE ECONOMY AND THE
ENVIRONMENT.
AND WE SEE NO REASON WHY
INGLEWOOD AND ITS SURROUNDING
COMMUNITIES SHOULDN'T HAVE THE
SAME OPPORTUNITIES.
I WILL ALSO MENTION THAT TODAY
HAVE PASSED OUT OF THE SENATE
WITH THE THIRTY FOUR ZERO VOTE.
I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON AB
NINE EIGHT SEVEN AND WILL LET
THEM.
MY WITNESSES TESTIFY AS WELL.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS --
JO LAYING ON BEHALF OF MURPHY'S
PULL AN AFFILIATE OF THE LOS
ANGELES CLIPPERS.
I JUST LIKE TO EXTEND THE
REMARKS OF OF MISS KAMLAGER-DOVE
OF FIRST OF ALL.
TREMENDOUS KUDOS MISTER CHAIRMAN
TO YOUR STAFF WHO WORKED
TIRELESS HOURS AND COUNTLESS
HOURS.
BEEN HELPING US TO ARRIVE --
WHAT THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN
DESCRIBED AS A BILL THAT THAT
NOT ONLY IS GONNA?
IT A VERY EXCITING PROJECT TO
HAPPEN.
BUT IS ESTABLISHING.
A NEW PRECEDENT FOR SHOWING HOW
YOU CAN DO A PROJECT LIKE THIS
AND ALSO.
ACCOMPLISH ALONG WITH THAT
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPROVEMENTS FOR
THE COMMUNITY.
UP THIS DEVELOPMENT IS IN THE
DISADVANTAGE COMMUNITY IT'S IN A
TRANSIT STARVE COMMUNITY AND AND
MISTER PALMER IN THE CLIPPERS
HAVE MADE A COMMITMENT TO MAKE
THIS INVESTMENT IN THIS
COMMUNITY KNOWING THAT IT'S
HARDER TO MAKE THAT KIND OF
INVESTMENT AND ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY.
IS THAT.
SOMETIMES THE INFRASTRUCTURE THE
TRANSIT DOESN'T EXIST TO HELP
YOU DO THINGS.
WHAT YOU'RE COMMITTEE STAFF?
HELPED US TO DO IS TO CRAFT A
BILL THAT SETS A STANDARD NOT
ONLY FOR GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS NOT ONLY.
FOR ENERGY EFFICIENT BUILDINGS
BUT ACTUALLY A WAY TO
FUNDAMENTALLY.
CHANGE AND IMPROVE.
POLLUTION EMISSIONS IN THE
COMMUNITY AND WE'RE DOING THAT
WITH TWO PRIMARY COMMITMENTS ONE
IS THAT. 50% OF THE MITIGATION
THAT'S REQUIRED TO MEET THE NET
ZERO GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS.
MUST OCCUR AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
WHICH WERE COMMITTED TO IN THE
COMMUNITY [inaudible]
SECONDLY.
IN ADDITION TO THAT WE HAVE WE
HAVE COMMITTED TO ALSO TAKE
STEPS TO REDUCE BOTH KNOCKS AND
PARTICULATE EMISSIONS BY
[inaudible]
SIGNIFICANT TARGETS AND WE ARE
COMMITTED TO A THIRTY MILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT. TO TO ALL OF
THESE FUNDAMENTAL ENVIRONMENTAL.
IMPROVEMENTS THAT WILL MAKE THIS
PROJECT.
NOT ONLY ONE OF THE STATE OF THE
ART ARENAS BUT THE GREENEST AND
WE THANK YOUR STAFF WITHOUT HIM.
ASK YOUR SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS GOT
WHICH ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PATRIOTS COUNCIL.
pMETAL WORKERS THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERSTHE ELEVATOR
CONSTRUCTORS UNION THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION OF UTILITY
EMPLOYEES.
I HAVE HAD --
THE FORGE HAD BEEN VERY
FORTUNATE TO HAVE WORKED ON ALL
OF THE STADIUM BILLS OF THIS
NATURE GOING BACK FOR A VERY
LONG TIME.
AND BECAUSE OF THE WORK OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND THE SPONSORS AND
THE AUTHOR --
IT'S WITHOUT QUESTION THAT THIS
BILL SETS A NEW BAR --
AND IT IS THE HIGHEST STANDARDS
WE WE HAVE SEEN.
BUT I WANT TO TALK WITH THE JOBS
IMPACT I KNOW YOU HEAR US TALK
ABOUT JOBS QUITE A BIT BUT
WHAT'S REALLY UNIQUE ABOUT THIS.
ABOUT THIS PROJECT.
IS THAT AS YOU KNOW IT'S CO
LOCATED NEXT TO WHERE THE RAM
STADIUM.
A CONSTRUCTION PROJECT IS
CURRENTLY UNDERWAY IN ALL OF YOU
MANY OF YOU FLY OVER THAT EVERY
WEEK TWICE.
SEE THE WORK GOING ON THAT
PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT.
AND THIS PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT
BOTH REQUIRE A 30% LOCAL HIRE A
REQUIREMENT.
NOT JUST IN INGLEWOOD BUT OF THE
SURROUNDING ZIP CODES AND MISTER
CHAIRMAN I KNOW YOU'RE AWARE
THAT.
MANY OF YEARS OF CODES --
ARE ENCOMPASSED IN THAT.
SO WHAT WE'VE DONE IN THE RAMS
PROJECT IS WE'VE RECRUITED.
HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF
APPRENTICES FROM THOSE
COMMUNITIES FOR WHO FOR THE
FIRST TIME EVENT ACCESS --
TO THE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY AND
IS THAT PROJECT WINDS DOWN WE'RE
GOING TO NEED SOMEPLACE TO
TRANSITION THOSE APPRENTICES.
AND THEY'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
STEP RIGHT NEXT DOOR AND BUILD
THIS ARENA IN ITS IT'S IT'S
GOING TO JUST FURTHER CAREER UP
THE LADDER.
WE'RE VERY PROUD OF THAT WE
WOULD WELCOME ANY THE MEMBERS TO
COME DOWN TO THE SITE MEET THESE
APPRENTICES SEE WHAT GREAT.
WORK WE'RE DOING WITH THEM AND
SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE WOULD
URGE AND I'VE OUT.
GEN ARE MEMBERS JOHN WHITE I'D
BEEN ENVIRONMENTAL CONSULTANT TO
THE MORE PEOPLE PROJECT AND I
HAVE WORKED WITH THE SPONSORS.
A AND THE AUTHOR IN DEVELOPING
THIS PACKAGE AND WITH YOUR STAFF
AND WITH THE SENATE STAFF AND
WHAT I CAN SAY WITH WITHOUT ANY
HESITATION THIS IS THE SINGLE
BEST COMBINATION OF REQUIREMENTS.
THAT WE'VE EVER PUT TOGETHER FOR
A PROJECT LIKE THIS IT HAS OUGHT
NOT JUST OFFSETS IT HAS LOCAL
MITIGATION FOR HALF OF THAT.
IT HAS NOT JUST GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSION REDUCTIONS BUT ALSO
LOCAL AIR QUALITY IMPROVEMENTS
AND SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS IN
ENVIRONMENTAL INFRASTRUCTURE SO
WE WOULD ASK FOR YOUR ARRIVAL.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS VERY
BROAD WITH THE TEAMSTERS OUR
UNION IS STEAM BECAUSE WE
REPRESENT NOT ONLY PEOPLE ON THE
CONSTRUCTION SIDE.
WE REPRESENT PEOPLE WHO WORK AT
THESE STADIUMS WHEN THEY'RE
COMPLETED.
PARKING AND SECURITY AND ALL
KINDS OF JOBS IN THE AND SO
THOSE JOBS WILL BE THERE.
FOR OUR MEMBERS FROM THE
COMMUNITY YOU KNOW FOR EVER.
FULLY ON AND THAT'S A HUGE A
HUGE THING FOR THEM SO ON I'LL
OF OF JOIN THE OTHERS IN URGING
AN AYE VOTE ON THIS.
REALLY GOOD BILL THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT ANY FURTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
BILL PLEASE COME FORWARD.
YOU CHAIR MEMBERS THAT'S ARE THE
OTHER BEHALF OF STATE BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL.
THE REASONS ALREADY STATED
HUNDREDS OF A PROMISES THAT ARE
IN AROUND THAT AREA THIS AREA
NEEDS ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT WE
WANT TO THANK YOU AND YOUR STAFF
FOR PUTTING TOGETHER.
AN ENVIRONMENTALLY SOUND PROJECT
MAKES WITH ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
THAT WILL BENEFIT THIS BUT NAY
REALLY REALLY REALLY DOES NEED
THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
O. DESTE RILEY I AM A RESIDENT
AND BUSINESS OWNER AND THIS
EVENING WHEN I WAS BORN THERE.
THIS COMMUNITY HAS LACK JOBS AND
INFRASTRUCTURE SINCE I CAN
REMEMBER SINCE I WAS A KID.
I THINK THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
WILL BRING A LOT OF BENEFIT TO
OUR COMMUNITY I THINK THE SUM
YOU SHOULD VOTE YES ON BANK.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN A
COMMITTEEMAN AIMS DEXTER HOME
THE PAST PRESIDENT OF THE RULE
TO CLIP OF INGLEWOOD.
HIGH AHEAD RESEARCH SUPPORT THIS
PROJECT OF CITY BOMBER HAS EVEN
BEFORE THIS PRODUCT WAS --
THOUGHT OF ACTUALLY BOUGHT OVER
THOUSANDS OF EYEGLASSES FOR ALL
THE STUDENTS IN IN WHAT UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IS MADE AN
IMPACT IN THE GOING TO BE WHICH
WAS PAYING IN ON THEM THOUGH.
INWARD UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
WORLD IS VERY THAT'S COMING UP
SO THEY ARE READY TO START AND
MAKE IT IMPACT RIGHT NOW SAW SAY
PLEASE VOTE YES ON THIS MEASURE
BUT I MY NAME IS DERIVED
MCCALLUM I'VE BEEN.
IN THE INGLEWOOD SINCE AREA
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY FIVE
WORKING ON ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
AND I'M REALLY HERE REPRESENTING
THE TWENTY SEVEN OTHER IN WHAT
RESIDENT THAT CAME UP THIS
MORNING.
UNFORTUNATELY RAN OUT OF FLIGHTS
TO GET THEM BACK HOME WE HAVE TO
GET [inaudible]
HERE BUT HERE YOU SAY --
WE JUST HOPE YOU US A SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MORNING MR HER MORNING GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE%
ROBERT SMITH I'M WITH THE
PAINTERS AND ALLIED TRADES IN
LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA.
AND NOT ONLY DO WE HAVE.
AND BEEN ABLE TO BRING IN A
PROMISES TO OUR DISTRICT OF MY
DISTRICT COUNCIL ACTUALLY
REPRESENTS THE OUR CLASSIFIEDS
AT THE INGLEWOOD UNIFIED.
AND WE'VE VIEW.
THE RAMS PIECE.
CLIPPERS PIECE IS ACTUALLY IN
THE FUTURE WILL HELP.
THIS THIS UNDERPERFORMING SCHOOL
DISTRICT FINANCIALLY JUST FROM
THE TAX BASE THAT THEY WILL
BRING AND WE HAVE A LOT OF
MEMBERS WORKING ON THAT SITE.
AND WILL HAVE A LOT OF MEMBERS
WORKING ON THE NEXT SITE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
MY QUEST REPRESENTING DISTRICT
COUNCIL SIXTEEN PAINTERS AND
ALLIED TRADES IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
JOSS DELUDE GATES ON BEHALF OF
LA COUNTY AND I JUST WANTED TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FAR TIRELESS
WORK AND EFFORT ON THIS MEASURE
AND WE ARE PROUD TO SUPPORT THE
BILL THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
KATIE DONNIE YOU DROUGHT THIS
ACCOUNTS OF LABOR'S ALSO IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KURT BACHMANN OF BILLS AND
WILSON ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
INGLEWOOD IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY FURTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
IN A WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL PLEASE COME.
FOR GOOD EVENING ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS MARIA ONLY HOPE.
EVENING AGAIN IF MARIA WHO WAVE
LEYVA MCGUIRE ATKINS PREMISE
JEEP FORUM.
AB NINETY SEVEN IS COMPLETELY
UNNECESSARY THE CLIPPERS DO NOT
NEED DESIGNER LEGISLATION.
THEY CAN USE EXISTING LAW A. B.
NINE HUNDRED TO SEEK TO EXPEDITE
ANY SEQUEL LITIGATION.
THEY HAVE THE TIME.
THE CLIPPERS HAVE COMMITTED TO
PLAYING STAPLES CENTER UNTIL.
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR AND THERE'S
NO REASON TO GRANT THEM RELIEF
FROM MANY OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL
STANDARDS AND MAYBE.
NINE HUNDRED MORE IMPORTANTLY TO
THE CONTRARY OF WHAT WAS STATED
AND SENATE COMMITTEE HEARINGS
AND WHAT THE CITY AND CLIPPERS
OF TOLD THE PUBLIC.
THE BILL STILL INCLUDES PRIVATE
RESIDENCES.
I LIKE OAKLAND WHICH WOULD
REPLACE AN EXISTING STADIUM OR
DEVELOP IN AN INDUSTRIAL AREA
THE CLIPPERS ARENA WOULD GO INTO
A RESIDENTIAL COMMUNITY.
THE FORUM APPRECIATES THE
THOUGHTFUL WORK OF THE SENATE
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY COMMITTEE
AND JUDICIARY COMMITTEES AND
FROM WHAT I HEAR YOUR COMMITTEE.
AND THE CHANGES MADE TO THE
INITIAL BILL TO TRY AND ALIGN IT
FURTHER WITH AB.
NINE HUNDRED BUT THERE REMAINS
AND SO REASON FOR A BI.
NINE EIGHTY SEVEN THIS COMMITTEE
REJECTED A SIMILAR BILL LAST
YEAR AND WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THAT YOU DO THE SAME TODAY.
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING TURN MEMBERS DAN
POEM FOR THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL --
IN OPPOSITION AS YOU'VE HEARD IN
MY PREVIOUS TESTIMONY ON SIMILAR
BILLS.
THE COUNCIL'S CONCERNS WITH A AB
NINE EIGHTY SEVEN FOCUS SOLELY.
ON THE ADVERSE IMPACTS THESE
EXPEDITED JUDICIAL REVIEW BILLS
HAVE.
ON THE COURTS AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY.
ON THE LITIGANTS THAT WE ARE
CHARGED WITH SERVING IN A MANNER
THAT IS SUPPOSED TO ENSURE.
EQUAL ACCESS TO JUSTICE WE TAKE
THIS CHARGE VERY SERIOUSLY.
HE A CENTRAL PROBLEM WITH THIS
BILL.
AND ALL OF THE OTHER MEASURES
THAT ARE MODELED AFTER THE
EXPEDITED JUDICIAL REVIEW SCHEME
THAT BEGAN IN.
TWENTY ELEVEN WITH THE ENACTMENT
OF AB NINE HUNDRED AND SB.
TWO NINETY TWO IS ALLOWING A
SPECIAL CATEGORY OF SECRET CASES.
TO CUT TO THE FRONT OF THE LINE
AHEAD OF ALL OTHER LITIGANTS.
pUNDERMINES THE PUBLIC'S TRUST
AND CONFIDENCE IN OUR COURT
SYSTEM.
AND CONFLICTS WITH OUR
FUNDAMENTAL RESPONSIBILITY TO
DISPENSE FAIR AND IMPARTIAL AND
PARTIAL JUSTICE.
IN EACH AND EVERY CASE AND FOR
THOSE REASONS THAT THE COUNCIL
IS.
OPPOSED AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR NO VOTE ON CONCURRENT STINK.
AND THAT I AYE WAS A GENEROUS IN
ALLOWING THAT.
OTHER WITNESSES TO TESTIFY YOU
KNOW.
IF YOU WANT TO SET THE TABLE ERA
CAN NOW BE CUECA CAO JUST CIRCLE
CALIFORNIA ALSO OPPOSED AND NOT
ON THE MERITS THE PROJECT AT ALL
THE JUST ON THE PROCESS OF A
POTENTIALLY TRUNCATING
LITIGATION AND IMPACTS COULD
HAVE ON LITIGANTS NOTION ABOUT
THANK YOU.
ARE THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
[inaudible]
SEEING NONE --
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE STARTING WITH MR
ACOSTA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
OF I WORKED ON IT BUT YOU KNOW
SIMILAR BILL LAST YEAR WITH
MISTER BRADFORD WE ARE UP.
SUPPORTIVE OF THAT PROCESS LAST
YEAR I'M.
HAD SOME ISSUES OBVIOUSLY WITH
THEM A DEMAND BY TO SEE THAT
THAT'S OUT OF THIS BILL.
AND WE DON'T --
WE DON'T HAVE THAT ISSUE HERE --
I YOU KNOW.
HAVE ALWAYS BEEN CRITICAL OF THE
PROCESS OF OF ANY KIND OF
EXEMPTIONS FOR SEQUINED NOT FOR
BUT AFTER THESE KINDS OF
PROJECTS BUT NOT FOR HOUSING
HOWEVER.
I'M ALSO A REALIST AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT --
WE HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE IN THE
COMMUNITY THAT --
YOU KNOW ARE RELYING ON THESE
KINDS OF INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS
AND JOBS CREATORS AND THE YOU'VE
HEARD ABOUT THE FACT THAT WE'VE
GOT A PREMISES GOING TO WORK AND
LEARNING.
YOU KNOW NEW TRADES WE'VE GOT
DISADVANTAGED YOUTH IN THESE
COMMUNITIES AND AND AND I AM ONE
OF FIVE BELIEVE THREE MEMBERS
HERE FROM LOS ANGELES --
AND I REPRESENT THE BOTH THAT
THE CITY AND THE COUNTY.
I AM VERY CLOSE TO THIS AREA
SPEND A LOT TIME DOWN IN THIS
AREA.
AND I HAVE WELL OVER THE YEARS.
YOU KNOW ALL THE ALL OFTEN
LAMENTED THAT THE FACT THAT IT'S
BEEN KIND OF A BLACK HOLE IN A
LOT OF WAYS IT'S A WONDERFUL
COMMUNITY OF THIS WONDERFUL
VIBRANT --
PEOPLE DOWN THE THIS IS THE KIND
OF THING THAT GIVES COMMUNITIES
A SHOT IN THE ARM IS THE KIND OF
THING THAT BRINGS UP ENTIRE
NEIGHBORHOODS AND COMMUNITIES
AND DISTRICTS AND HELPS --
AND THAT'S I GOT CUT OFF BY THE
CHAIR BECAUSE I WAS GOING TO
LONG APPARENTLY.
THANK YOU SO CHAIR I GUESS THAT
MIGHT THAT'S LIKELY TO HIT
WARNING BUT I ONLY HAD ONLY NEED
A COUPLE MORE SECONDS YOU KNOW --
WE HAD SOME SNAFUS ON ME I'M
GETTING ON TO THE BILL THIS GO
AROUND AND AND AND THOSE THINGS
DO HAPPEN.
ARE HOWEVER DOESN'T --
IT DOESN'T DIMINISH MY
ENTHUSIASM.
FOR THE FACT THAT WE NEED THIS
KIND OF THE PROJECT WE BUT WE
ALSO NEED.
ANY KIND OF RELIEF WE CAN FROM
THE ONEROUS WEIGHT OF OF SEQUENT
NOT THE ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW.
NOT THE ENVIRONMENTAL MITIGATION
THAT'S ALL HERE.
BUT WE NEED TO HAVE SOME A
CLARITY FOR VERY LARGE AND SMALL
PROJECTS I WILL I WILL SAY.
I HOPE WE CAN CONTINUE WORK WITH --
THE OPPONENTS I AND THE
PROPONENTS IN THE FUTURE ON
HOUSING.
BECAUSE IT'S DESPERATELY NEEDED
IT'S NEEDED IN THIS PARTICULAR
AREA GOING FORWARD BUT AT THE
SAME TIME --
I WILL TAKE A THIS PROJECT AND
SUPPORT IT AND I'D LIKE TO MOVE
THE BILL --
AND AND GET THE SUB PROCESS
MOVING THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AND THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD AGAIN.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU [inaudible]
MR SHOWN.
THAT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
AT AT THE RISK OF HAVE A SEAT
NEXT TO MY SEAT MATE FOR THE
REST THE EVENING.
AND HEAR ABOUT THIS I AM SURE
AGAIN TO GET GET I I AM ACTUALLY
GOING TO OPPOSE IT.
BECAUSE WE IS.
SURE TO GRAY PROJECT WILL DO
SOME GREAT THINGS THAT'S NOT MY
ISSUE AT ALL.
THIS BILL AND ALL THE PREVIOUS
ONES AND I HAVE A VERY
CONSISTENT VOTING RECORD ON
THESE ARE REALLY BUILT AROUND A
FLAWED PRESUMPTION.
THAT SICK WAS AN ISSUE SEEK WAS
A PROBLEM.
AND HAVING SERVED TO THE LOCAL
LEVEL AND ON ANY NUMBER OF
PROJECTS FOLLOWING THIS IF THE
PROCESS.
IT CAN GET DONE.
IT DOES GET DONE A GETS DONE ON
A REGULAR BASIS BUT THESE KINDS
OF PROJECTS.
ARE RAISED TO A LEVEL THAT.
THAT WE NOW SEEM TO BE WILLING
TO SET ASIDE.
GOOD POLICY IN ORDER JUST TO
MOVE SOMETHING THAT THAT GETS
ARGUED BECAUSE OF ITS COMPELLING
NATURE.
AND I I I JUST CAN'T.
FOLLOW THAT LOGIC AND I'M GONNA
STICK MY CONSISTENCY AND A
POSTER PROJECT.
OKAY MOTIONS WERE MADE BY MISTE
COSTA SECOND BY MISTER FLORA --
MISTER MCCARTY THEN ISRAEL'S.
THANK YOU THAT I HAVE SEN KIND
OF BIG PICTURE --
COMMENTS ABOUT THIS AND THAT AND
NINE HUNDRED GOING FOR IT BUT
JUST I WANTED TO GIVE YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO ADDRESS TO
THE ISSUES THAT CAME UP FROM THE
OPPOSITION.
UP ONE WAS WE HEARD LAST YEAR
AND I THOUGHT THAT THE THAT YOU
OR YOUR TEAM.
THE CITY TRIED IT YEAH TO
ADDRESS THIS BUT RESIDENTIAL
PROPERTIES BECAUSE I WAS THE
CLAIM AND OTHERS THAT.
THE FORMER SRO HOTEL.
SELECT FEW MONTHS AGO AT JERICHO
AT YOUR REQUEST.
AND SO SO THAT YOU CAN ADDRESS
THAT.
AND ALSO.
AND I'LL GET TO THOSE LATER
YESTERDAY OVER ARCHING QUESTION
BOT Y. NINE HUNDRED IS INFERIOR
AND DOESN'T WORK.
IF THAT CLIPPERS DO HAVE A LEASE.
AT THE STAPLES CENTER.
WHERE THEY CALL OKAY WITH THE
LAKERS UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
INCH?
AND DID THE NOTION WAS WE NEED
DESKS WE NEED CERTAINTY BECAUSE
NINE HUNDRED WILL THAT A COUPLE
YEARS DOWN THE ROAD.
AND THAT'S UNDERSTANDING SIX
YEARS BEFORE LEASES UP SO.
YOU CAN ADDRESS THOSE TWO ISSUES.
HOW AM I WILL LET THE WITNESS
HAS JUMPED IN BUT I DO WANT TO
SAY THAT THAT'S THE DESIGN IN
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE SERENA
WILL NOT IMPACT RESIDENTS --
BUT YOU CAN EXPAND.
OSAMA MCCARTY GELANG
REPRESENTING THE BRETT MURPHY
SPOLE.
THE CLEAR SIMPLE ANSWER ON THE
RESIDENTS QUESTION IS THE
AGREEMENT WE HAVE WITH THE CITY
WHICH IS A PUBLIC DOCUMENT
PROHIBITS THE DESIGN OR USE OF
ANY RESIDENTIAL OR CHURCH
PROPERTIES WHATSOEVER SO JUST
PROHIBITED.
AND IT'S A LEGAL DOCUMENT THAT
WE HAVE.
SECONDLY I THINK IMPORTANTLY.
THE QUESTION IS ABOUT TIMING.
SO FROM A TIMING STANDPOINT.
THIS IS TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND WE
HAVE TO BE READY TO OPEN THE
DOORS FOR THE SERENA RATE BE
ABLE TO DEMONSTRATE TO THE NBA
THAT WE HAVE THE DOORS OPEN BY.
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR WHEN YOU LOOK
AT WHAT IT TAKES TO DO THAT.
THAT SIX YEAR PERIOD.
THE FIRST TWO YEARS INVOLVE
[inaudible]
DESIGN.
YEAH I OUR WORK GETTING THROUGH
THE FINALIZATION OF THE I. R..
THE SECOND TWO YEAR PERIOD.
ALLOWS FOR BOTH THE LITIGATION
PERIOD AND OTHER CHANGES OF MY
NET TO BE MADE TO THE ARE BASED
ON THE MEDICATION.
THAT LEAVES YOU TWO YEARS TO
BUILD. TWO YEARS IS.
JUST ON THE RAGGED EDGE HERE IN
SACRAMENTO THEY HAD JUST OVER
TWO YEARS TO BUILD IT AND LIKELY
THEY MADE IT.
IN OCTOBER BEFORE THE FIRST GAME
WAS REQUIRED TO BE DONE.
THAT'S THE TIMELINE WE FACE IF
WE CAN'T DEMONSTRATE THAT WE CAN
MEET THAT TIMELINE AND IT REALLY
IS THAT SIMPLE TWO YEAR PERIOD
[inaudible]
THEN.
MISTER PALMER THE TEAM IN THE
NBA WILL BE FORCED TO LOOK.
ELSEWHERE.
AND SO WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
DEMONSTRATE THAT AND THAT'S THE
NEED THAT'S WHY THE AB.
NINE SYSTEMS THAT WORK.
SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE AB NINE
HUNDRED AS IT CURRENTLY EXISTS.
COULD VERY WELL WOULD SUNSET
DURING OUR CERTIFICATION PARA.
NOBODY KNOWS WHAT HAPPENS.
IF THE CURRENT AB NINE HUNDRED
SUNSETS IN THE MIDDLE OF OUR
CERTIFICATION PROCESS.
WE DON'T KNOW WHETHER THAT WORKS
OR NOT NUMBER ONE NUMBER TWO AB.
NINE HUNDRED REQUIRES THAT WE
DEMONSTRATE.
WITHIN THE FIRST YEAR OF THE
OPERATION THEY WERE IN A 15%
VEHICLE TRIP PRODUCTION.
WE'RE IMAGE STRANDS AT STAR
COMMUNITY.
WE KNOW WE CAN'T MEET THAT
STANDARD IN THE FIRST YEAR.
WHAT THIS STILL BILL DOES IS
ALLOW US SIX ADDITIONAL YEARS TO
MEET THAT STANDARD?
AND THE PRICE FOR THAT SIX
ADDITIONAL YEARS IS ALL OF THESE
ADDITIONAL ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPROVEMENTS THAT THIS BILL
INCLUDES.
YOU'VE HEARD IT TALKED ABOUT.
THE HIGHEST STANDARD OF ANY OF
THESE BILLS HAS COME ALONG AND
AND IT TRULY IS SO THE ANSWER TO
THE QUESTION IS.
AB NINE HUNDRED DOES WORK
BECAUSE THE TIMING.
AND BECAUSE OF NEEDING THE EXTRA
TIME TO MEET THAT STANDARD.
WHILE WE'RE DOING OTHER
ENVIRONMENTAL THINGS AND THE
RESIDENTS ISSUE IS IS IS DRIVING
THE DESIGN INCLUDES NO
AND OUR AGREEMENT WITH THE CITY
SPECIFICALLY PROHIBITS THE USE
OF ANY RESIDENTIAL OR CHURCH
LOTS PERIOD.
AND IN THIS ELEMENT OF GOOD
POINT --
DIDN'T.
BY THE WAY IT AS IT RELATES TO
THAT 15% TRIP PRODUCTION
STANDARD THAT THIS REQUIRED TO
BE MET BY TWENTY THIRTY IF WE
DON'T THIS BILL BUILDS AND FOR
THE FIRST TIME [inaudible]
ACTUALLY ENFORCEMENT OF THESE
PROVISIONS ON THE BACK IT
INCREASES THAT STANDARD WHAT 15%
STANDARD TO A 17% STANDARD.
AND THEN SUBSEQUENTLY AT TWENTY
SO.
THERE'S THERE'S NOT ONLY.
STANDARDS THAT HAVE TO BE MET
BUT THERE'S ACTUALLY ENFORCEMENT.
FOR THE FIRST TIME TO MAKE SURE
THOSE STANDARDS ARE.
THANK YOU.
THAT PITCHER ON TO DO WE HAVE
SOME RESPONSE ON THE RESIDENTIAL
I TELL YOU WHAT IF YOU'D LIKE.
YES I IT'S JUST A CLARIFICATION
ON THE RESIDENTIAL THE BILL
INCLUDES A LIST OF ASSESSOR
PERSONAL NUMBERS OF PROPERTIES
BY A SUCH A PERSON BIRCH AND TWO
OF THOSE PROPERTIES ARE
RESIDENTIAL PROPERTY WITH
RESIDENCES IN THEM AND PEOPLE
WHO HAVE.
SUBMITTED A LETTER TO THE
COMMITTEE.
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL SO I
I'M JUST CONFUSED ON THAT POINT
OF THE NO RESIDENTS IS INCLUDED
IF.
THE PROJECT AREA AS DEFINED IN
THE BILL INCLUDES TO RESIDENTIAL.
MR LIKE MISTER CHAIRMAN IF IT'S
OKAY I'LL RESPOND TO THAT IT'S A
REAL SIMPLE ANSWER --
IN THE SENATE AND I THINK ALSO
YOUR COMMITTEE SELF NOT FELT
MORE COMFORTABLE IF IN THE BILL
WE WOULD ACTUALLY NAMED THE
PARCEL NUMBERS THAT ARE SUBJECT
TO THE STREAMLINING SO EVERYBODY
UNDERSTOOD EXACTLY.
THE ASSESSOR PARCEL NUMBERS THAT
INCLUDE.
THERE ARE IN FACT. TO
RESIDENTIAL PROPERTIES THAT ARE
INVOLVED IN ONE OF THOSE
PERSONAL.
THE CITY IS PROHIBIT US FROM
USING THEM AND ARE DESIGNED DOES
NOT INCLUDE THEM.
WE CAN'T HOWEVER LEGISLATIVELY
CARVE OUT A COUNTY ASSESSOR
PARCEL NUMBER.
THE LEGISLATURE'S NOT AUTHORIZED
IF WE COULD WE WOULD DO THAT.
BUT WE CAN'T.
IF THOSE TWO RESIDENTIAL
PROPERTIES ONE AS A SINGLE THING
HOUSE ONE IS A TRI PLEX.
IF THEY CHOOSE TO SELL WERE
HAPPY FOR THAT.
IF THEY DON'T SELL THAT'S FINE.
TOO IT'S IT INVOLVES THE
DRIVEWAY FOR THE ENTRANCE FOR
ONE OF THE PARKING [inaudible]
STRUCTURES AND ONE STRUCTURES ON
EITHER SIDE.
BUT THE CITIES OR PROHIBIT US
FROM USING FROM TAKING HIM.
AND THE DESIGN DOES NOT INCLUDE.
AND SO THE THAT'S THE ANSWER TO
THAT.
WHY A ARE THOSE TWO RESIDENCES
IN PARCELS THAT INCLUDE THE
BILLS THAT WE CAN'T LEGISLATE
SPLIT THE PARCEL BUT THE CITY'S
PROHIBIT US FROM USING THEM AND
GIVE THAT THE DESIGN?
OR AN ATTACK [inaudible]
ALRIGHT OKAY.
SO I'M I'M GOING TO OPPOSE THIS
I'M NOT SIX BRING US TODAY THAT
LET YOU KNOW I'M DONE.
I THINK I WANT TO SHARE A FEW
THINGS ON I ONE THAT THE TIMING
OF NINE HUNDRED I DON'T THINK
MATHEMATICALLY WORKS OUT BECAUSE
TEARS AND DESIGN TEARS
CONSTRUCTIONS FOR YEARS.
AND THIS IS GOING TO TWENTY
EIGHTEEN TWENTY FOUR SIX YEARS.
THEN WE CAME HERE LAST YEAR
THOSE OXY SEVEN YEARS SO.
SO SO FOR IT FOR THAT --
BUT I GUESS IT THAT THE BIGGER
PICTURE IS THAT --
AND YOU MENTION THIS TO IS IS
NINE HUNDRED MAY EXPIRE DURING
THAT I THINK WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING AT NINE HUNDRED BECAUSE
I THINK THIS IS A GREAT PROJECT
FOR INGLEWOOD IN LOS ANGELES.
COUNTY -- A
BILLION DOLLARS IN INVESTMENT
THERE WITHOUT ONE PENNY PUBLIC
SUBSIDY IS SOMETHING TO BE.
APPLAUDED DOWN THE STREET WE
HAVE A BEAUTIFUL ARENA BUT IT'S
TAXPAYERS UNIT PAYING SEVEN
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
NEXT THIRTY YEARS.
AND DEBT SERVICE SO HERE NO
PUBLIC SUBSIDY --
I TOTALLY GET THE SIGNIFICANCE.
AND THAT AND THAT --
THE OVERALL CENTER THERE WITH --
THE RAMS FOOTBALL STADIUM UNDER
CONSTRUCTION.
BY JUST THINK IF YOU LOOK BACK
IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN WHY WE
CREATED AB NINE HUNDRED BECAUSE
THE LEGISLATURE BEFORE WE'RE
HERE.
WE DON'T LIKE PICKING WINNERS
AND LOSERS.
WE DON'T LIKE PICKING THE PERSON
WITH THE BIGGEST CHECKBOOK.
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS LOOKS LIKE.
CRYSTAL CLEAR.
AND IT'S JUST I THINK REALLY
REALLY UNFORTUNATE.
AND I WOULD MUCH RATHER I AND I
KNOW THAT.
NINE HUNDRED IS PROBLEMATIC FOR
YOU FOR A FEW REASONS AND I DID
HEAR YOU SAY THE LITIGATION
WOULD TAKE UP YEARS.
TO SO IT'S IT WOULD BE --
THE FACT THAT NINE HUNDRED MAY
EXPIRE THE NINE HUNDRED DOESN'T
ALLOW YOU TO DO THAT TRACK
TRANSPORTATION IMPROVEMENTS IN
THE FIRST YEAR.
I GET THAT I WOULD MUCH RATHER
TODAY OPEN UP NINE HUNDRED AND
PUT THOSE NEW ELEMENTS IN
[inaudible]
NINE HUNDRED SO THEN.
THE GOVERNOR THROUGH THE ENTIRE
PROCESS CAN PICK THESE.
LEADERSHIP PROJECTS WHICH HAVE
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT --
LABOR AND ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS
AND HAVE A FAIR PROCESS WE DON'T
HAVE.
TO DO THESE ONE OFFICE ONE AT A
TIME BECAUSE IF YOU LOOK AT THE
LIST.
WE'VE HAD A FEW SOME PROJECTS IN
PENCIL OUT OF LOS ANGELES.
TURNABOUT FARMER'S FIELD AND SO
FORTH SOME SOME HAVE.
SOME ARENA STADIUM PROJECTS HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO MATERIALIZE UNDER
NINE HUNDRED SO IT'S JUST
EXTREMELY DISAPPOINTING THAT WE
HAVE -- TO
PICK AND CHOOSE WINNERS AND
LOSERS IN THIS PROJECT WHEN
SMALLER PROJECTS WITHOUT THE
RESOURCES DON'T HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COME UP HERE.
HIGHER ADVOCATES INCOME ADVOCATE
FOR IT AND AGAIN.
THAT'S WHY WE CREATED NINE
HUNDRED TO MAKE A SIMPLIFIED
STATEWIDE --
PROCESS FOR FOR BIG ECONOMIC
DON'T PROJECTS I THINK OVER A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS. TWO
OUGHT TO PARTICIPATE ON AND I I
GET TO THE POINT THAT YOU MAKE
IS CRYSTAL CLEAR SOME OF THE
PROJECTS THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
ABLE. TO PARTICIPATE.
FOR NINE ARE VERY DIFFERENT
ECONOMICALLY.
AND DIVERSELY WISE THAN THE
PROJECT THAT YOU'RE REPRESENTING
HERE TODAY SO I I DO TRULY
UNDERSTAND THE FAIRNESS PROJECTS --
BUT HAVING A PROJECT THAT JUST
PICKS ONE OUR VILLAGES PICKS ONE
PROJECT I DON'T THINK IT'S GOOD.
PUBLIC POLICY AND AGAIN I PREFER
US TO LOOK AT THAT.
THE NINE HUNDRED ENVELOPE AND
FIX THAT ITSELF THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR CHOW. OH I'M SORRY
DID YOU HAVE SMOKE Y. JUST
WANTED TO CLARIFY THE TWO TWO
INTO ITS THIRD TWO YEARS
LITIGATION CERTIFICATION AND
DESIGNED SO IT DOES GO TO SIX
YEARS -- AND
YES IT IT CAN BE --
YOU KNOW HAVING THE BIGGEST
CHECK BUT BUT IN THIS INSTANCE
IT'S ALSO ABOUT HAVING THE
BIGGEST WILLINGNESS TO COMMIT TO
INGLEWOOD AND WE HAVEN'T REALLY
SEEN THAT FROM A DEVELOPER IN A
VERY LONG TIME.
MY AS DID THE RAMS UTILIZE THAT
AGREE WITH THE SENTIMENT.
NOW ASK A QUESTION OVER
QUESTIONS CHECK YET SO I KNOW
THAT.
THIS IS A BILLION DOLLARS BUT
RIGHT NEXT DOOR THE RANCHER
SPENDING TWO BILLION DOLLARS
THEY ARE BEAUTIFUL FOOTBALL
STADIUM NEXT USE PROJECT.
DID THEY UTILIZED NINE HUNDRED
OR OF A ONE OFF LIKE THIS TO GET
THAT DONE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN ARE CHAU LANGA
KNOWS THE IS THE RAM STADIUM WAS
DONE TO A LOCAL INITIATIVE.
THERE'S A BALLOT BOX EXCEPTION
TO THE ALRIGHT [inaudible]
CHAU.
MY QUESTION'S BEEN ANSWERED THE
ON THE QUESTION WAS OF THE
AVERAGE AMOUNT OF TIME IT TAKES
TO LITIGATE THAT I THINK YASSER
QUESTION TWO YEARS THAT'S THE
AVERAGE.
IS THAT CORRECT [inaudible]
PLUS MINUS [inaudible]
THANKS [inaudible]
PLAYWRIGHT THERE'S RATES.
THANK YOU IT'S SUCH A PLEASURE
TO COME IN PM AN ALTERNATE.
UNDER SUCH AN IMPORTANT --
SUCH SUCH IMPORTANT BILL.
I DID WANT TO ASK OF THOSE SOME
QUESTIONS REGARDING THE
COMPARISON WITH A V. --
NINE HUNDRED AS NOTED IN THE AND
ALICE'S.
ON THE G. H. G. NEUTRALITY --
COULD YOU TELL US A LITTLE BIT
MORE ABOUT THAT THIS 50%.
MORE THAT'S BEING REQUIRED O
MEET THIS [inaudible]
SO.
MISTER CHAIRMAN ASSEMBLYMAN
REYES --
WE'RE NOT ONLY REQUIRED TO MEET
THE NET ZERO GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSION STANDARDS.
THAT IS IT AB NINE HUNDRED BUT
FOR THE FIRST TIME THE BILL
ACTUALLY REQUIRES THAT 50% OF
THE MITIGATION REQUIRED TO MEET
THAT STANDARD.
OCCUR LOCALLY IN THE COMMUNITY.
ITS FIRST TIME THAT STANDARDS
EVER BEEN APPLIED IN ADDITION.
WE'RE REQUIRED TO ADDRESS BOTH --
LOCKS EMISSIONS CAR MISSIONS AND
PARTICULATE EMISSIONS.
WHICH AFFECT THE ENTIRE LA
REGION AND SO WERE REQUIRED TO
DO BOTH OF THOSE THINGS THOSE
ARE NEW STANDARDS I THINK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF WOULD.
SURE HAVE NEVER BEEN APPLIED TO
A BILL LIKE THIS AND THEY ARE
THE HIGHEST STANDARDS HAVE.
AND I NOTICED ALSO THAT IT WAS
SUBJECT TO A AND INVESTMENT CAP
[inaudible] THIRTY MILLION.
HOW IS THAT AMOUNT REACHED AND?
WHY THE SEVEN REYES --
I THINK IT WAS REACHED BY
LOOKING AT THE AMOUNT OF
ADDITIONAL POLLUTION ON TOP OF
WHATEVER THE PROJECT WOULD
CREATE THE IDEA WAS.
WE NEED.
TO IMPROVE THE EXISTING
POLLUTION IN THE AREA MINUS THE
PROJECT.
AND SO THERE WAS A TIME AGE GOAL
TO ME. FOUR HUNDRED TONS OF KNOX
EMISSIONS AND TEN TONS OF THE
TWO POINT FIVE PARTICULATE
EMISSIONS.
AND SO THAT NUMBER WAS DERIVED
FROM THE FROM THE GOAL OF WHAT
IT WOULD TAKE TO ACHIEVE THOSE
REDUCTION.
IF I MAY.
IT REVIEWING THE THE ANALYSIS --
THOSE PROVIDED TODAY AND THE THE
HISTORY ON THIS.
RIGHT I THINK IT'S CLEAR THAT
FIRST YOU SELECTED.
AND AN EXCELLENT AUTHOR.
I THINK HAVING ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COME LONGER --
DOVE.
ALL THROUGH THIS PROVIDED --
GREATER INSIGHT FOR ME ANYWAY TO
BE ABLE TO HAVE SOMEONE THAT I
CAN SPEAK WITH. TO TWO ANSWER
SOME OF THE QUESTIONS THAT I HAD
EARLIER --
AYE I DO WANT TO NOTE AS AN
ASIDE.
THAT IT'S REFRESHING TO HAVE A
WOMAN SIT.
THE TABLE WHEN ALL OF THE
PROPONENTS.
WERE ALL MEN.
AND I THINK THAT SOMETHING THE
SOMETIMES WE NEED TO LOOK AT SO
THAT TO A WE NEED TO BE AWARE.
OF THAT I WOULD DO APPRECIATE
THE FACT.
THAT THE LOCAL JOBS ARE COMING
IN IT'S GOOD TO SEE LOTS OF THE
ARE REPRESENTATIVES THE DO TAKE
CARE OF THOSE JOBS.
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT ARE AND WHAT
YOU MIGHT BE ABLE TO DO FOR
INGLEWOOD AND THE SURROUNDING
AREAS [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ALRIGHT [inaudible]
THIS SEGMENT.
DOES.
THINK YOU VERY MUCH I'M BY A
PLEDGES THAT I'D MISSED A LITTLE.
EARLIER PART OF THIS --
BUT I HEARD THIS.
WHEN I WAS HERE?
MEMBERS LAST YEAR THE YEAR
BEFORE --
WITH MISTER BRADFORD IN MISS
BURKE -- AND
JUST JUST TO GO ON THE RECORD
THAT I WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS
AGAIN THIS YEAR I THINK YOU
TIGHTENED UP THE RESTRICTIONS
EVEN MORE THAN WERE IN PLACE
BEFORE --
AND I THINK EVERYONE SEEMS TO
AGREE THAT WHILE.
IT MAY BE GOING AROUND THE
PROCESS IN SOME RESPECTS THAT
THE FROM ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES
HAVE BEEN PRETTY THOROUGHLY
ADDRESSED.
AND THAT NIGHT I JUST TAKE IT A
STEP SYRUP Y. NOWHERE SERVING ON
NATURAL RESOURCES AND INCREDIBLY
DEDICATED AND DEVOTED TO THAT
BUT I ALSO REPRESENT A COMMUNITY
OF STOCKTON MUCH LIKE THE BALLOT
COMMITTEE OF INGLEWOOD THAT HAS.
OFTEN BEEN OVERLOOKED WHEN IT
COMES TO JOBS AND INVESTMENT AND
BEEN COMMITTED DEVELOPMENT.
AND SO WHEN YOU LOO AT THAT
WHOLE KIND A PACKAGE OF WHAT
THIS PROVIDES.
I'M GONNA COST BENEFIT ANALYSIS
AND AGAIN NEW GOING ABOVE AND
BEYOND.
REALLY TRY TO MITIGATE SOME
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES --
THAT THE AIR WE BREATHE IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT BUT WE
ALWAYS PRE BETTER WHEN WE HAVE
JOBS.
MISLIM ON THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD TO AND
I I THINK IT'S PROVIDED YET
ANOTHER IMPORTANT CONVERSATION --
ABOUT A OUR PROCESS IN THE
STATE'S ABOUT SEQUEL ABOUT WHAT
IT MEANS AND IN THE FUTURE --
I WILL NOT BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL AND TODAY I DIDN'T IN THE
PAST I HAVE INTO --
AND I THINK I WHILE I COMPLETELY --
IF YOU KNOW INGLEWOOD'S AN AREA
I'M FAMILIAR WITH I HAVE FAMILY
THERE.
AND THEY'RE ALL THE TIME --
AND I UNDERSTAND --
THE IMPORTANCE OF WHAT THIS
MEANS I'LL SO I'D KNOW THAT SEEK
WHAT I'M.
PLEASE ALSO AN IMPORTANT ROLE.
I'M FOR COMMUNITIES AND
THINK THAT I HOPE --
AS WE SEE THESE BILLS COME
FORWARD THAT WE THINK ABOUT IT
ME I HEAR IT EVERY YEAR WHAT WE
CAN AND YOU ARE WE EVER GONNA
HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT SEQUEL.
ARE WE GOING TO DO SOMETHING SO
THAT WE DON'T SPEND AT LEAST I
FEEL 30% OF THE TIME NATURAL
RESOURCES.
I'M HEARING BILLS ABOUT SEQUEL
EXEMPTIONS. TO ME THAT'S THE
BIGGER PROBLEM --
THAT SO MUCH TIME IS SPENT ON
TRYING TO GO AROUND THE RULES
INSTEAD OF MEANT FOCUSING ON
WHAT THE WHAT AT THAT TEACHING
MAYOR MAY NOT NEED TO HAPPEN --
BUT AGAIN AS HAS BEEN CONSISTENT
WITH MY VOTING PATTERN I WON'T
BE -- VOTING
ON THIS --
BUT I DO APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING
[inaudible]
FOR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
HIS WONDERS [inaudible]
AND ALRIGHT I HAVE A FEW
COMMENTS.
WELL FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU MS
COME LAGER FOR A YOU'RE
[inaudible]
TIRELESS [inaudible]
PERSISTENT.
WORK ON THIS BILL WE'VE HAD MANY
CONVERSATIONS --
BOTH IN THE BUILDING AND OUTSIDE --
AND YOU HAVE.
FOR CERTAINLY --
MADE A STRONG CASE THAT --
THAT ANGLE WOULD [inaudible]
DESERVES.
THESE JOBS IN THIS INVESTMENT AS
MUCH AS ANYONE --
AND THAT --
YOU HAVE CONSISTENTLY ASKED YOU
KNOW.
IF IT'S GOOD ENOUGH FOR
SACRAMENTO IF IT'S GOOD ENOUGH
FOR OTHER COMMUNITIES WHY NOT
FOUR INGLEWOOD.
AND I THINK THAT'S A IF A FAIR --
ARGUMENT TO MAKE --
MY THE CONCERN HAS ALWAYS BEEN
AS AS I THINK YOU'VE HEARD WITH
THE SUB SEVERAL THE MEMBERS ON
THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
ARM.
AND WHAT ABOUT AB NINE HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY NINE HUNDRED IS
SUPPOSED TO BE THE STANDARD --
WHEAT WE PASSED --
THIS LAW. FOR V. ENVIRONMENTAL
LEADERSHIP PROJECTS --
FOR THE LARGE PROJECTS THAT.
TO WITH EXTRAORDINARY --
ENVIRONMENTAL.
THE PROVISIONS --
THAT -- THAT
WORSE BOTH TO PROVIDE THAT
STREAMLINED PROCESS --
FOR THE SEQUEL A MINISTRY OF A
JUDICIAL REVIEW --
AND SO THAT'S ALWAYS BEEN MY
CONCERN I MEAN --
AS MR MCCARTY INDICATED --
WHEN DO WE STOP MAKING
EXCEPTIONS?
FOR THE POCKET --
FOR PROPONENTS --
THAT -- THEY
HAD TO WHILE THEY CERTAINLY
PROMISE --
THE THAT THE JOBS AND
INVESTMENTS IN THE COMMUNITY --
I I THINK YOU KNOW THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL --
AND MSG.
MAKES A VERY IMPORTANT POINT I
MEAN THEY BY.
ACHIEVING ARE BY REQUESTING THIS
TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY DAY
CERTAINTY.
IF IS A CERTAINTY OF OF
RESOLVING DISPUTES WITHIN THAT
[inaudible]
DEFINITIVA AREA.
THAT IN ESSENCE IS GOING TO
ALLOW.
THIS PROJECT TO CUT IN LINE --
IN FRONT OF OTHER CIVIL AND
CRIMINAL CASES THAT THERE.
THAT MAY BE PENDING --
IN THE COURT THAT WOULD HAVE
JURISDICTION OVER ANY SUCH
APPEALS.
SO -- WE
WE'VE STRUGGLED AS WITH THIS --
FOR FOR FOR MONTHS --
AND AYE WE WE HAVE --
REACHED THE POINT WHERE.
WE'VE AGREED THAT IF.
YOU ARE ASKING. FOR SPECIAL
TREATMENT THROUGH THIS BILL.
THEN YOU NEED TO MAKE
[inaudible]
STRAORDINARIO PROVISIONS --
TO JUSTIFY.
THE SPECIAL TREATMENT.
I JUST WANNA MAKE OF ALL OF THAT
THAT A CLEAR TO EMPHASIZE THE
POINT THAT.
WE DON'T WANT THE EXCEPTIONS TO
BECOME THE ROLE AND I THINK
THAT'S WHAT MS LAMONT WAS WHO
WAS REFERRING --
TO WE SPEND SO MUCH TIME --
ASKING --
FOR MOVE REVIEWING REQUESTS FOR
FOR A EXCEPTIONS TWO SEQUEL AND
IT'S SEQUEL AS I'VE STATED.
IN THE AND THIS COMMITTEE'S
PREVIOUS HEARING ON ON THE
SUBJECT MATTER [inaudible]
IT PROVIDES.
CIVIL RIGHTS FOR PEOPLE TO BE
ABLE TO BE INFORMED AND AND TO
BE ABLE --
TO ENGAGED AND IN THE PROCESS OF
OF CHALLENGING OR QUESTIONING --
IN A SIGNIFICANT.
DEVELOPMENTS THAT ARE OCCURRING
IN THEIR THEIR COMMUNITY --
I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT THIS IS
NOT A SEQUEL EXEMPTION.
BUT THAT THIS IS --
A SEQUEL STREAMLINING IN TERMS
OF THE TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY DAY
ADMINISTRATIVE JUDICIAL REVIEW
PROCESS SO TO THAT EXTENT.
YOU NO I WANNA MAKE IT
ABSOLUTELY CLEAR THAT THE PEOPLE
OF ENGLEWOOD WILL STILL HAVE.
I SEQUEL PROCESS AVAILABLE TO
THEM.
AND SO WEIRD.
TALKING ABOUT.
SHORT CUTTING CO ARE DENYING ANY
CIVIL RIGHTS TO ANYONE IN IN THE
INGLEWOOD COMMUNITY --
I THINK --
THROUGH.
THE NEGOTIATIONS THAT WE'VE BEEN
ENGAGED TO LAST A A COUPLE WEEKS --
PROPONENTS HAVE MADE SIGNIFICANT
CONCESSIONS TO ACHIEVE WHAT SOME
OF DESCRIBE AS IT THE HIGHEST
STANDARDS IN THE ENVIRONMENTAL
MEDICATIONS AND THE IN
PARTICULAR.
THE I'M NOT LESSEN 50% OF THE G.
A SHE EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS TO BE
ACHIEVED LOCALLY.
THAT IS A DIRECT BENEFIT TO THE
PEOPLE OF ENGLEWOOD.
AND AND TO BE A SURROUNDING
COMMUNITIES --
DE.
PROVISION OF LOCAL CLEAN AIR
IMPOSING --
THE REQUIREMENT OF REDUCING THEN
KNOCKS AND CRITERIA POLLUTANTS
THE PM TWO POINT --
FIVE AMONG OTHER PROVISIONS THE
THE THE VEHICLE.
TRIP PRODUCTION OF PROVISIONS
THAT THESE --
DO USE THAT.
A NEW STANDARD THEY GO ABOVE AND
BEYOND -- AB
NINE HUNDRED AND AND OTHER PER
AND THESE OTHER SPECIFIC
PROVISIONS.
AND SO FOR THAT REASON --
ALTHOUGH IT.
STILL BUGS ME I IN MY GUT --
YOU KNOW I I I DO BELIEVE THAT
THE THEY UNIQUE NATURE OF THIS
PROJECT WILL BE.
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS A
SPECIAL IN A COMMUNITY LIKE IN
THE WOULD --
COMBINED WITH THE SIGNIFICANT
COMMITMENTS THAT YOU HAVE MADE --
FOR THE ENVIRONMENT ON
MEDICATION --
IS THE REASON WHY I WILL BE
SUPPORTING ON YOUR BILL --
MISS COME LIKE WHICH LIKE CLOSE.
THINK YOU CHAIR I WOULD JUST
LIKE TO ADD THAT --
THE KNEW STANDARDS THAT WERE SET.
WE'RE ACTUALLY BECAUSE OF YOUR
LEADERSHIP --
AND YOUR COMMITMENT TO ACTUALLY
REALLY REVIEWING THIS BILL AND
ITS IMPLICATIONS.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO ADD THAT I
THINK THAT JILLIAN'S ZUCKER WHO
IS THE PRESIDENT OF STAPLES
WOULD ACTUALLY AGREE WITH THE
SENTIMENT RAISED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RADIUS.
ABOUT ON THE NEED FOR MORE
GENDER DIVERSITY IN THESE KINDS
OF CONVERSATIONS AND IN THESE
INDUSTRIES IN WHICH WE SET AND
WORK AND WITH THAT I WILL JUST.
THANK EACH OF THE MEMBERS FOR
YOUR COMMENTS AND YOUR
COMMITMENT TO THE INTEGRITY OF
THIS COMMITTEE AND ITS
PHILOSOPHIES.
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
RIGHT BEFORE WE ARE A GOD OF THE
ROLL CALL AYE --
I'VE HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH THAT
SOME OF YOU --
BUT WHILE I WILL BE SUPPORTING
AYE I WANT TO MAKE IT CLEAR THAT --
INDIVIDUAL COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE.
AS ALWAYS ENCOURAGED ABOUT YOU
BECAUSE AB NINE EIGHTY SEVEN BY
KAMLAGER-DOVE OF THE MOTION IS
THAT SENATE AMENDMENTS BE
CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS ROUTE TO CHANGE ROUTE
THIRTY AYE ACOSTA AYE ACOSTA AYE
CHAU.
CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA AYE LIMON NOW LIMON NO
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY NO MELENDEZ [inaudible]
REYES.
REYES AYE STONE [inaudible]
STONE NO [inaudible] THREE SIX
THREE THE BILL ITSELF.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS MEETING
IS [inaudible]
ATTORNEY [inaudible]
WE